I'm gonna pull up this Twitter thread we
briefly went over before it's from
America First legal and just we'll go
through this they say following the
Twitter files America First legal has
obtained new documents uncovering a
secret Twitter portal U.S government
officials used to censor dissenting
covid-19 views and violate the First
Amendment follow along they say this is
what 500 plus 500 plus page release in
August of 2021 the head of Google's news
lab for the Asia Pacific region APAC
emailed a CDC vaccine confidence
strategist to invite her to the Apex
trusted media Summit cdc's vaccine
confident strategist then emailed the
event planner for Google's APAC trusted
media Summit noting her excitement over
being invited to what she referred to as
the coolest misinformation fighting
Speakeasy and I want to go through every
single uh every single element of this
but I want to highlight and then we'll
go through this the fact that it's not
just Twitter okay YouTube obviously I
love this one
YouTube has rules on what you can and
can't say about vaccination and covet
here's the funny thing those rules have
dramatically changed over time is that
YouTube accepting responsibility for
false information for posting
misinformation now YouTube can argue we
were only fighting following the
guidance from officials well now we
actually have some testimony from some
of these officials that they actually
based their decisions off nothing so
here's what we have
the government it's not it's not just
voucher setting guidelines it is the the
federal the executive branch with direct
access to Facebook to Twitter to YouTube
to censor information they don't like
often with zero Merit
and where does that bring us
including satire including humor
including legal political speech that
couldn't be in the public discourse
because some politicians some fat cat
bureaucrat some some Karen Becky said I
don't like this speech I'm going to
censor it that that's the the idea that
a politician could say those ideas
shouldn't be in your mind is is like
Peak orwellian Peak tyrannical it's
something that we should push back
immediately because these people are
essentially trying to push thought
control mind control on the general
public and there's no other way of
arguing it I don't see it any other way
we we used to talk about how in the
United States you could mock your
political leaders you know it's one of
the few countries in the world where you
can make fun of your present all stuff
you still can't to a certain degree but
when people went online and made fun of
fauci the government intervened and got
these people banned well not only that
but remember that The Intercept just put
out that article as well about the DHS
and the disinformation governance board
and how they were trying to essentially
censor speech regarding the withdrawal
of Afghanistan racism and social Justice
or racial Justice I'm sorry and then
again of course covid-19 as well so
going back to that freedom of speech do
we really have the ability to question
our government officials like we talked
about with Twitter they have backtracked
on a lot of their covid-19 policy I for
one almost lost my entire YouTube
channel because I was reporting what the
own CDC was saying to us and then you
know highlighting the hypocrisy of um
how they were kind of going back and
forth with things I got censored for
that multiple times
they did that to Crowder Crowder got a
strike for just reporting what the CDC
was saying yeah yeah that was a fun time
the past two years have been a lot of
fun on big Tech yeah yeah let me let me
pull this real quick uh sorry but
Michael Tracy says Joel Roth said he had
weekly meetings with FBI DHS Etc
throughout 2020. let me stress this he
writes where is he since 2018 I've had
regular meeting to the office of
Director of National Intelligence
Department of Homeland Security the FBI
and Industry peers during these meetings
they said blah blah blah hacked
materials about Hunter Biden and here's
what we know
was the FBI directing Twitter to take
things down it appears not
but there was a former FBI agent who got
hired by Twitter who was working
alongside the FBI and then taking things
down so let's just be for real was the
FBI directly doing it any sane person
would say yes to think that like this
guy's ousted from the FBI goes work to
Twitter then keeps talking to the FBI
about how to operate and it's not the
FBI pulling the strings spare me Tim
honestly I'm at the point where I'm like
uh put the FBI in the same category as
the ATF and the CIA abolish all of them
because I truly haven't seen anything
good come of the FBI is this the same
FBI that's been in trapping Americans
for you know probably since it's
Inception I I don't know what good has
come out of the FBI because maybe I'm
just misinformed on this The X-Files
that show is awesome they also you know
arrested peaceful preachers at abortion
clinics very true there thank you to the
FBI for talking they were singing they
were singing the hymns very aggressively
well look you guys know that silent
prayer is violence yeah absolutely like
those thoughts those can hurt people
honestly being you know having
dissenting views in 2022 is violence
this room is violence I can feel it
emanating okay
what was uh oh yeah conto probe
definitely something worthwhile to doing
definitely something that was honorable
and not deceitful and not working in
secret in order to cause chaos within
political movements I've gotten to the
point in my career with politics where
sometimes I just don't even want to look
back historically at what our government
and what our intelligence agencies have
done to us and done to the American
people because it's just black pills me
to no end I'm like okay so the CIA is
the one that brought LSD and crack to
the American public got it the FBI is
the one who's been entrapping Americans
for the past couple of years and they
were directly tied to January 6th got it
don't forget about funding cartels and
terrorist organizations and Isis was
fast and furious uh no no Fast and
Furious was uh I think uh yeah DEA
you'll look at any of our intelligence
agencies um project Veritas just came
out with their own expose about the HHS
and I was reporting on NVM mink earlier
this year about how essentially we're
trafficking children via taxpayer per
dollar you know utilizing the cartel the
Border everything going on over there
our government complicit in all of it
we're paying for child trafficking
trafficking for crying out loud and um
yeah everyone's just kind of okay the
FBI is not that bad they did a really
good job protecting Epstein for 30 years
so true yeah they made sure that he was
able to continue his operations when
when the victims and the children were
coming forward they made sure to shut
them up but they did a great job at that
in the 90s yeah so this is the point
that I was making about the US like
there was a period where their their
power was kind of absolute you know that
that stuff they were doing that was
America no he didn't like it of course
and then you're a conspiracy there's if
you thought it but think about where we
are now it used to be that if you came
out and said there was a cabal of
wealthy a lead to a trafficking children
using a private island a bit Yeah crazy
and now it's a definitive fact like
Maxwell's literally in prison for this
Epstein is no longer living now it's
like you asked Bill Clinton about it and
it's like please baby please do do not
question him about that okay nobody
needs to question Joe Biden about these
things either if it's not not on the
approved media question list we're just
going to go ahead and overload you know
maybe I should put this another way
maybe it's wrong to say there's no us
anymore maybe for a period there wasn't
one maybe this corrupt deep State
controlling things was when the U.S was
suppressed and what we're seeing now
with us calling it out and and pointing
it out exposing the corruption and
stopping it is the Resurgence of America
Tim I've been looking into the Council
on Foreign Relations and how they've had
Direct ties to you know our upper
officials in government and media
exactly in the corporate world again
this just goes back to me being super
black filled because you read about all
of these groups that have had ties to
who is allowed to be in our government
and it's this entire illusion of choice
so I do agree with that sentiment a
little bit more where it's like well
maybe things have always been this way
we're just seeing it now in open uh
because we have you know Freedom of
Information via the big text some what
to see this maybe it's always been this
way
Tulsi gabbard also a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations a group
started by significance David
Rockefeller that has codified a lot of
the secretive not secretive meetings in
institutions that they have had within
our National Security State and the
corporate banking world as well
instituting their policies covertly and
also uh publicly as well the larger
point that I really wanted to make about
this and I'm so happy you brought up the
Council on Foreign Relations this is
like the topic that I love love to
especially talk about they banned me uh
from from their facilities uh previously
they're doing something right but this
is exactly how they work it's a
revolving door between a lot of people
with government in the private world and
not private world and to think that that
you know their their accomplishments
that their you know job leaves when they
leave that physical office is is again a
misnomer they're all interconnected
they're all dating each other they're
all related to each other they're all
going to the same parties they're all
doing the same drugs they're all doing
unspeakable things that I can't even
mention here on this broadcast in
Twitter and there and and they also run
larger extortion operations on each
other to keep each other in check so
this this power grid system has many
different layer layers to it and I think
we're seeing some people are arguing
that you know maybe things aren't
getting worse maybe we're just finding
out about what they really are
um and and I I think that's an aspect
that I think we should be considering
here are we finding out more and
realizing the truth of this world that
was hidden from us before or is it
really getting that bad what are you
guys we're finding out more about what
has always been but it's also a set of
new challenges right now we need to
protect our constitutional rights as
American citizens so we have encryption
to protect our First Amendment right you
have decentralization to protect your
First Amendment right because
centralized systems are vulnerable you
have ghost guns you have the ability to
3D print weapons to protect your second
Amendment right like you can't rely on
some external Force to protect your
rights those are your rights and we need
to work together to protect our rights
as Citizens Luke and I'm so glad that
you said that because uh what I have
realized is Ian well Luke's station
sorry you're both white men you guys
look exactly the same
um
how can you what do you mean Luke's a
person of color exactly I apologize can
I say what can I say you know you know
that Slavic people are people of color
right yeah I do now I'm sorry I just
told you I'm a bigot one more apology
and it's okay before we get to real tell
me what I was saying was right again
what were you what were you what were we
just talking about oh so you're right
that's on Foreign Relations so the mass
is what I have realized now going out uh
you know Across America because for the
past six to seven months I really have
dedicated my life to going to the Bronx
Skid Row Portland Kensington Avenue in
Philadelphia because I have wanted to
see what has been going on in these
cities and I have wanted to see what the
American public has been experiencing
but I realized that the masses and you
know the majority of people genuinely do
need somebody to think for them and
that's why it has been so easy for our
government to just come in and take over
do something like this we all see it in
plain sight and everyone's just like
okay oh well the government is you know
kind of subverting the Democracy
whatever it is what it is
um
it's so rare to have people who are
original thinkers and willing to stand
up for themselves and I think people
like Tim Poole are going to come save
them they think people like Donald Trump
are going to come save them no people
have to go and stand up for their own
rights and freedoms you have to be the
one to make the change and you have to
get rid of that mentality of oh well
someone else will do it for me someone
else will say this for me like no you
have to be the one who gets active in
your community and makes the change
because that's why America has gotten to
where it currently is is because of weak
men weak women and weak-willed people
who refuse to actually stand up and
speak out against everything some people
would say we are changed but also I want
to make a correction here it wasn't the
DEA between uh that was behind Fast and
Furious it was the ATF so just uh yeah
just the correction there our other
favorites the ATS yeah yeah I gotta say
like the DEA shouldn't exist the ATF
shouldn't exist and at this point
neither should the FBI so but like you
know to be honest like the DEA and the
ATF are like top contenders because like
the DEA
Ani I just yeah I'm sorry oh yeah
marijuana schedule one right just
there's so much broken stuff about this
the atf's weird because like what is
Firearms have anything to do with
tobacco like what the hell those are
completely different organizations yeah
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time